un enseignant vient d'être décapité dans
des constituants des conditions
monstrueuse et des roues est absolument
déroutante pour des propos qu'il aurait
pu tenir l'école de la république c'est
l'école de la république
elle est laïque la parole y est libre et
on doit pouvoir dire tout ce qu'on veut
dans cette ignoble c'est monstrueux ma
première réaction c'est évidemment
l'unité nationale il faut qu'on se
soutienne tous il faut qu'on soit tous
solidaires face à ces atrocités à ces
comportements barbares il ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que personne n'est à
l'abri de ce type de comportement et que
nous nous devons collectivement ensemble
parce que nous sommes tous en
responsabilité que ce soit les
parlementaires dont je fais partie où le
gouvernement de prendre le sujet à bras
le corps et d'essayer d'apporter une
solution à ce genre de choses il ne faut
pas qu'en france pays des libertés pays
de la liberté d'aller et venir pays de
la liberté de s'exprimer ce genre de
faits puissent se reproduire
une autre fois on a franchi un nouveau
cap c'est inédit et c'est encore plus
monstrueux parce qu avec tout le respect
que j'ai pour les forces de l'ordre la
mission qui est la leur et le fait que
je ne tolère pas qu'il puisse être
attaqués dans le cadre de leur mission
c'est encore plus inadmissible pour un
enseignant qui s'occupe de nos enfants
qui est du nos enfants qui a foi dans la
profession compliqué qui est la sienne
et on vient de franchir un cap
absolument intolérable ici ce soir